es suficiente la propuesta presentada
hoy por la comisión para que las grandes
empresas energéticas se dan parte de sus
ganancias para amortiguar los costos de
la crisis
bueno estimados yo creo que lo que hizo
la mandataria de la comisión europea es
tratar de poner un poco de calma a esta
a este problema urgente que está por
tener la Unión Europea como consecuencia
de la proximidad del frío del Invierno
no lo que se produjo en Europa es un
desacople energético es decir Europa ya
no cuenta con la energía proveniente de
la federación rusa y esto en principio
crea un problema muy grande puesto que
hasta antes de la de esta guerra hasta
antes de febrero de 2022 Europa contaba
particularmente Alemania el motor de la
Unión Europea contaba con la con la
energía con el gas de territorio
territorio de Rusia Pero esto se acabó y
por lo tanto yo creo que Europa no está
preparada para afrontar una crisis
energética
como la que como la que va a afrontar e
incluso sus puertos para
abastecerse de gas no están preparados
para otra o para otro para otro
suministro o gas proveniente de otro de
otros países no de manera que lo que yo
creo que hizo la la mandataria esta
tarde poner tranquilidad a lo que
sospechan que se les puede llegar a
escapar de la mano puesto que van a
subir los precios de la energía puesto
que Rusia estaba cerca de Europa
particularmente de Alemania y ahora la
energía va a tener que venir quizás de
las zonas de de
Qatar quizás de la zona del caucaso de
serbayán en el estado que está ahí esto
es explicar mayor precio de manera que
lo que es la hermandad tarea es tratar
de tranquilizar un poco pensando o
haciendo ver a la a la madurar los
europeos de que esto está es el momento
de emplear nuevas matrices energéticas
no
Pero esto no va a ocurrir inmediatamente
de manera que el tiempo que se le viene
a Europa es un tiempo muy difícil en
materia de precios
se mencionaba usted la capacidad de
Europa para hacer frente a la situación
Y es que se avecina un invierno muy
difícil para el bloque sin embargo
ponerle ahí insiste en mantener las
sanciones a Rusia hasta que punto puede
resistir el bloque sin los hidrocarburos
rusos
Bueno yo creo que lo que le ha faltado a
Europa y esto siempre lo digo es una
visión geopolítica propia Yo creo que si
Europa quiere ser lo que dice Alemania
una potencia institucional
encima Como dijo la mandatario de la
comisión europea van a proseguir con el
apoyo a Ucrania para tratar de vencer a
Rusia bueno Esto va a significar mayor
involucramiento de Europa en el
conflicto no cierto un involucramiento
que seguramente implicará ajustar más
sanciones nuevos anillos de sanciones
pero yo creo que aquí Europa no es una
una ganadora Precisamente en este
conflicto y las consecuencias las está
pagando en materia económica
particularmente energética lo que yo
considero es que si Europa va a ser
realmente Una potencia civil la
experiencia no registra casos de
potencias civiles tiene que pensar en
sus intereses particularmente porque por
no pensar eso en sus intereses
la mandataria de la comisión dijo algo
importante hoy el lo que parecía
permanente está cambiando notablemente
en realidad comenzó a cambiar antes
muchos años antes de la pandemia y antes
de obviamente de la de la cultura Rusia
de manera que creo que le falta una
geopolítica propia